le noël de l'espoir un événement
traditionnel à chanteloup les vignes et
c'est en pleine préparation de ce
rendez-vous que la ministre déléguée
chargée de la vie de nadia et s'est
rendu dans la commune une action sociale
menée auprès des enfants de la ville
âgés de 2 à 11 ans avec la distribution
de 1429 cadeaux cette année dans un
contexte social particulier c'est
vraiment important de mener ce genre
d'action c'est ça permet de donner
sourire aux familles aux enfants avec
cette crise sanitaire ça c'est encore
plus paupérisées et là on en arrive à
avoir aussi des difficultés en ce qui
concerne ne serait-ce que l'alimentaire
sans compter tout
les impayés de loyer face à cette
urgence sociale les associations sont en
attente de soutien pour financer des
actions destinées aux familles en
difficulté une situation alarmante aussi
pour le tissu associatif sportif de la
ville
ces 37 5% de désinscription cette année
donc on va travailler là en début
d'année avec l'eau sans des associations
sportives match en train de créer mon
budget pour absolument qu'on les
accompagne faut absolument qu'on ait
l'assurance que l'état les accompagne
pour rappel catherine arts nous fait
partie des maires qui ont lancé un appel
au président de la république le premier
ministre s'est ensuite engagé à
consacrer 1% du plan de relance au
quartier politique de la ville objectif
financer différentes dispositif nous
avons voulu débloquer un fonds d'urgence
de 20 millions d'euros pour aider ces
associations de grande proximité comme
l'association l'espoir que nous avons vu
tout à l'heure il faut répondre aussi à
la question du chômage des jeunes dans
les quartiers par une réponse forte sur
les développements économiques sont
l'accompagnement à l'emploi
dans ce contexte la commune poursuit sa
mobilisation dans le cadre de la
rénovation urbaine
la visite de la ministre s'est conclue
avec la signature de la convention en
rue pour le projet destiné au quartier
lanoë